in a high growth startup
the legal teams tend to be relatively
small so you have your hands in
a lot of different places
[Music]
rachel alfred thank you for being on my
show how are you good thank you for
having me it's a pleasure good morning
to you
a good night to me you're calling from
ranana right
yes yes wonderful okay rachel i
i know nothing about what we're gonna
talk about which is most exciting for me
because
you know at this point after about a
hundred and something episodes it's
really exciting when i get to talk to
somebody and i have no idea what they're
going to tell me
so you know a little spoiler today
you're a senior legal counsel at lytrex
previously legal counsel at get but
you've transitioned from actually
you know traditional law and litigation
into technology law
so if fraud take me back rachel sorry
take me back
all the way you know back to when you're
you know getting your law degree
do you know you're going to be in tech
no i had um
no idea um i graduated law school and
i immediately started clerking for a
judge i thought i was going to be
a litigator in my mind i always had this
dream of
opening up like my own private practice
brick and mortar shop
um so i clerks for a year and then i
worked at a plaintiff's law firm
representing people who had been
wrongfully terminated from their jobs
involved
not necessarily tech right unrelated
completely unrelated
wow um so wait rachel what but you know
first of all litigation
paint me the picture how what does that
entail when you say you were a litigator
when you started out
so um litigators are lawyers who go to
court
and represent their clients in legal
disputes that find their
their way to the courtroom um so as a
lead as a clerk
um you're kind of like the judge's um
right-hand man um or woman
and you prepare all of the motions do
all of the the legal research behind the
scenes
the judge can make the proper decision
all the times that they say objection is
that what is that what it is
yes i think you froze for a second sorry
you can just
repeat the last no no i was joking to
ask you if you know
when you say to prepare all the motions
that's about you know saying the
objection
sure like in the movies okay so you see
go from litigation and then and then
where did and then where does the your
curve take you sure sure
so um what actually ended up happening i
was working at a plaintiff's firm
um and then i ended up moving to israel
um i met my my husband in new york and
um his work brought him back to israel
i came with i thought it would be
you know a one-year stint it's now been
five years
um and i quickly realized um when i
landed here
that i wasn't going to do litigation in
israel uh
you know every the whole hebrew you know
i i can get around but
litigation in hebrew is a whole
different ballgame
right um so i started realizing okay
what are my opportunities
here and a lot of the opportunities um
and you kind of have to reinvent
yourself which is a challenge like
taking
a step back to move forwards um
most of the opportunities for like
english-speaking
american lawyers are in tech or in like
the commercial space
so um i got a job
working at a boutique law firm i'm
representing lots of startups
this was like my first entry into
transactional work
um because before i had been you know
working on
like writing motions going to court
depositions
um there's a lot of different things you
can do in the law i've
been fortunate to like enjoy everything
that i've done
um and i worked there for about two
years and then
um i i just i wanted to move in house
i like it was something i thought would
be
fun um you know you get to actually ins
instead of representing
lots of clients you have one client um
you get to know your client really well
um so i actually um
my boss said get i like i emailed her
i saw that they were looking for a legal
counsel and i emailed her and i told her
i would really
um love to work for you and
one thing led to another um i ended up
getting hired there i worked there for
three years
um what does that mean what does that
mean
the legal council within a company like
get and whoever doesn't know
get is already i believe a unicorn right
an israel unicorn
where they provide ride sharing services
similar to uber and lyft
across the world get is focused on
different areas
particularly also israel but but what
does that mean to have a legal council
within
an organization like get
sure so basically what it means as a
legal counsel um
you are the like the in-house lawyer for
the company um so the
the company is your client in essence
like you have one client and that's the
company um
in in practice you still have like
hundreds of clients because when you're
in a
high growth um startup the legal teams
tend to be relatively small
so you have your hands in a lot of
different places it's not like you have
a hundred
of 100 clients you mean a hundred
different you know stakeholders within
the company who want who need your
assistance
under the get name but you're
considering them as a hundred different
kinds because they have different needs
exactly exactly so you may find yourself
working with
um you know the product team on issues
of like regulatory compliance like in a
ride-sharing company
there's there's tons of regulatory needs
to make sure that
your pricing is is compliant you may
find yourselves working with um
like developers on the data team because
um you know
ggpr ccpa um all of a sudden you need to
get all your
your data in place um working with the
finance team
on inter-company agreements um
investment rounds and supporting due
diligence
um your biz dev team on partnership
agreements so
every single stakeholder has totally
different needs
um actually this is like one of the
things i love about it because it really
never gets boring you have
insights into so many different
areas of the company so many different
people
um and you get to see like everyone's
different perspective
um but your your job as legal counsel is
essentially to
advise the company um to support them
and to manage their legal risk and
exposure
so are you a sort of are you the
pessimist in the group
in the startup no because i'm serious
because you know i'm thinking of a
startup organization everybody's so
excited everybody's like
yeah move fast and break things and and
all of a sudden you know when i think of
legal in this context of a startup i
think
you're like the downer the person who
has to say no so
i wouldn't i want to call it the
pessimist but we're not
always the most popular person in the
room um right
so there's there's a level of um
having to be comfortable being
uncomfortable
um especially when you work in in israel
where
conflict is just part of the game um
and and people always just um are so
upfront
so you you just have to be very
um clear know your your boundaries um i
like to think that
we're not the people who are saying no
that um we're
just coming from a different perspective
um people are
just we don't think the same way that
that we think
while we're also closing deals a lot of
the time we're also the same people who
you know have to pick up the pieces when
a deal goes sour
or uh when litigation ensues or
um you know unfortunately sometimes you
go through a bankruptcy event
and your legal counsel will be involved
in that so we just
we have a different perspective um but i
like to think of it as problem solving
um in that we look for creative
solutions
i love it okay so i already i have so
many questions already lined up in my
head with the but first one
at what point does a startup need a
legal council in-house
because you know most startups you know
when i when i incorporated my company in
high school with my with my good friend
drew we went into cooley
and we you know they did pro bono they
incorporated for us
at what point do we say okay now we're
big enough and we're ready to have
somebody
in-house to work full-time with us i
i think from what i've seen um generally
i don't know if that the ceo says oh i
now i want a lawyer in-house but usually
the board
um you know requires it as a company
matures
um after they've reached a certain level
of
investment and you know things like
compliance
become more important if you're starting
to think down the road about an exit
event
and you really need to have all your
ducks in order um
obviously you need this cfo and the cfo
kind of
comes i think before the legal council
and that's that's when it starts to get
more pressing okay okay that's
fascinating and
and then tell me a little bit about you
know the the inside the organization so
you're sitting there
a lot of the times you get to to work
with the different stakeholders in the
organization
and whether it's at get or at lytrex i'm
assuming that a lot of the times
the rationale that you bring to the
table on your decision making or your
processes
they're not always understood by your
colleagues right
and you don't necessarily always have
the time to go and explain why you need
everything the way that you need it do
you find that there's a lot of tension
with that or
or people do people sort of give you the
respect of okay you know what you're
doing we're gonna trust you
um i think it's a work in progress um i
i don't think you can expect anyone to
um just listen to you because i said so
um so
like everyone who you're working with
it's a relationship
um so what that's another thing i really
like about the job that you
you have to be like a people person um
so it's like relationships that you
develop over time you're working with
you know you're working with a lot of
different people but you're working with
the same people
day in and day out um day out so i
like my approach and and i'm sure you
can speak with different
lawyers they have different approaches
is i try to explain to them like
why i'm advising them in a certain way
sometimes if they really don't care
about the law they just want like a yes
or no
answer like that's nice just tell me
like
if i can do it or not um but it's also
so they can like understand the
reasoning
behind it um and it's not going to be
the last question they have so they can
kind of get us a sense of the direction
um of like what's okay what's not um
and it also helps them you know be
prepared for the next time so
they they have it on their radar and
they can actually like
reach out to me um if they think
something is
not kosher um so i think educating your
teams training them
um it's helpful for for everyone um
and you know in the end of the day like
yes i i have like an agenda as a legal
counsel but my agenda is really for the
the better of the company i'm not just
doing it because rachel feels like it so
it's it's really um
right educating the team so that they
realize that this is
important for uh like checks this is
important for the company not just
because my lawyer said so
that i mean that makes perfect sense and
i think that other i mean
then you are part of the organization
you're a part of the culture and then to
see you as such
a lot of it sounds to me that almost
every aspect of the startup scene has
changed
dramatically over the past 10 15 years
you know whether it's things
transitioning from top
down decisions to bottom-up decisions
responsibilities
you know different ways of going about
getting a startup off the ground
has the legal council arena within a
startup changed at all
over the past uh you know 10 15 years or
is it the same
sort of methodology same same types of
people
um that i i can't really say because i
haven't been a legal counsel like
in-house from your experience yeah
i would imagine so um just because the
industry has changed um
like the tech technology has changed so
i the way that things work now things
change so quickly because technology is
changing so quickly um
and you and because technology is
the regulations are also changing a bit
more quickly um than they used to
as well so that the pace is just so
fast especially in a high-tech company
um so i think probably the
the people who are you know want to go
in-house and be an in-house lawyer at a
tech company
particularly um like need to be ready to
think quickly have super
strong intuition because you will be hit
with issues that
you're not an expert in everything but
you have to
you have to know um still how to react
and
and when you know you need to seek
guidance from outside counsel who are
experts
no no 100 i mean one of the things that
i was just you know thinking about
in terms of the the legal world is that
you know companies have become so much
more globalized over the past
decade i mean if before you had a legal
council that were experts in the
jurisdiction let's look at get for
example
you know legal experts that are that are
concentrated in israel
and transportation laws for example and
all of a sudden you want to branch out
because that's what every company is
doing today
and all of a sudden you have expertise
in those different countries it's no
longer the same expertise you need to
have you need to expand your knowledge
right and not just within yet but but
every company that
you know is selling globally and today
almost every single company selling
globally
yeah it's a huge challenge because um
you know
everyone wants to be global um that's
how you make money right you don't make
money by staying in israel
um so it's
it's a challenge because you'll find
yourself in a situation um and every
industry is different like ride
sharing for example you might have
different um
you know taxi laws in new york city
compared to upstate new york and like
you're up
you're operating in the same state yet
that the taxi
rules are different um and the pricing
is different and all of these laws have
to be reflected in
your product right the price like
appears to
the end user um so that and then even
you know
negotiating that across you know
different countries in different
languages
um you know different tax laws it's
it's a lot of work um because you're
actually like seeking
um guidance from experts all over the
world
in all these different jurisdictions um
and and you have to decide okay are we
going to
um you know have what like bespoke
product for every single jurisdiction or
do we make a global solution
that will work for every single
jurisdiction
um it's a challenge it's definitely a
challenge but it's exciting and it gives
you the opportunity to work with
people all over the world who are you
know experts in their field which is
amazing i'm very curious how how long of
an
on-boarding process is it for a legal
council
traditionally when you enter a a tech
company and i'm
you know i'm making a comparison you
know as an engineer yeah you know having
just for example onboarded
into hippo insurance you know basically
within one or two days they expect you
to already be pushing code to production
i imagine it would be a little bit
longer for a legal council that has to
really get acquainted with the company
policies and legal right
it should but you're still hit the
ground running um because
usually by the time you arrive they they
really need you
um so um like yes you you do take some
time to like read you know your terms
and conditions your privacy policy
um you know under speak meet with you
know all the the
relevant stakeholders to understand the
different products and
roadmap but people are always pulling
you from the side saying like hey can
you review this
hey i have a question on this and you
quickly understand okay like
these are going to be the like the main
like
issues of law that i'm going to have to
become an expert in because every
industry is in
is very different right and you know
before i before i asked about you know
whether your colleagues and other
employees
in the organization understand your
decision-making processes
and i'm now i'm shifting the question
more towards the leadership does the
leadership
necessarily understand all the legal
intricacies behind the decision-making
you know i'm thinking about
the ceo senior vice president positions
these are people you know are making
like critical decisions
day in and day out and i imagine that
they're also the ones who are having the
most interaction with the legal counsel
as they are considering their options
how much do they generally understand
the legal you know the legal scene
behind these different decisions
um i think you they need to understand
it because ultimately these are also the
people who are
responsible for the company um they're
you know
directors and on officers so
um even more so
it's important for them to understand
because if they accept risk
um they're the only ones in the company
who actually have authority to
accept risk um so so
it's it's your job to explain the risks
100 you know the dissonance in my mind
is that at the end you know you think of
a start-up and a fast-growing company
you think okay you want to move quickly
you want to make decisions quickly and
you also delegate a lot of tasks to
other decision-making
authorities and you trust them and one
of these key figures i'm guessing is the
legal counsel but at the end this is one
area in which it's imperative that the
decision makers don't just rely on your
statements but they have to be able to
defend them later on
as you know especially since we're
talking about legal things here rachel
this has been so so great i have two
more questions but first before we end i
want to ask you for three words that you
would best use to describe yourself
um okay so i guess i'll choose like
words that are like
applied both like personally and
professionally yes
um reliable uh
hard working and up for a challenge
reliable hard working enough for a
challenge i love it and and right before
we leave
rachel talk to me a little bit about why
you're so passionate about what you're
doing
and you know coming in very fresh into
this world of
legal counsel why you know why
why now why in tech you could have
continued doing what you were doing
before
what excites you about the work that
you're doing today
i think it's like a combination of three
um
like three facets um i like working with
people
um i like problem solving and
uh especially in tech it's it's never
boring um you get exposure
to um like the most interesting
topics whether it's machine learning
privacy issues
um so it couldn't it's right there's
there's a cerebral part to it as well i
love it
rachel thank you very very much to
dagobah and have a fantastic day and
stay safe and stay healthy this is great
me too thank you so much bye take care
take care
you